Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American supernatural horror film
called “Carrie”. Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Margaret White is a deluded religious fanatic
who thinks everything is sinful, especially
if it is related to women, their bodies, and sex.
In the opening scene, she is on her bloodied bed,
screaming in pain and asking God to forgive her
sins. She is so unmindful of the real world that
she thinks she is dying of cancer when in reality,
she is in labor. When the pain finally subsides,
she looks in between her legs and freezes
in shock to see a newborn girl. Margaret
thinks that the infant is the result of the
sin she committed with her former husband.
She brings out a pair of scissors, getting ready
to murder the baby but cannot bring herself to do
it. The little girl is later named Carrie. Over
the years, Margaret forces her religious beliefs
on Carrie and doesn’t give her any freedom
at all. She refrains her from making friends,
talking to men, and doesn’t let her go to school
for most of her life. When Carrie turns sixteen,
children's rights activists forcefully make
Margaret let her daughter go to high school.
However, because of her antisocial and introverted
nature, Carrie is always made fun of. She never
talks to anyone and stares in shock when girls
show cleavage or couples kiss. The concept of
dating is foreign to her. One day, while
the students are playing water volleyball,
Carrie accidentally hits the popular girl Sue
in the head. Sue's friend, Chris, makes fun of
Carrie and everyone laughs at her. After the
class, they go to the shower room to change.
Carrie gets her first period while showering and
starts to panic. She has never been taught about
periods or anything that has to do with female
anatomy. The blood running down her legs makes
her think she is dying of an illness. She runs
around, frantically asking the girls for help.
Chris realizes that Carrie doesn't understand
what menstruation is and makes fun of her. Soon,
all other girls join and throw tampons at
her while filming her crying. Sue feels bad
for Carrie but doesn't stop the girls, scared to
be declared an outcast like her. They only stop
when the gym teacher, Ms. Desjardin arrives
there. Carrie starts having a panic attack,
screaming and crying even after the girls stop. To
calm her down, the teacher slaps her in the face.
As the girls walk away, Carrie stares at the light
bulb in anger and it coincidentally shatters. When
the principal is informed of the incident, he
asks Ms. Desjardin to punish the bullies as
she wishes. He also tells Carrie to calm down
because they have called her mother. However,
the thought of her mother finding out she
got her periods makes her even more nervous.
She hyperventilates and a water cooler
in the room shatters mysteriously.
Sometime later, Margaret comes to pick her
daughter and sees Chris and her boyfriend
fmaking out. She doesn’t want such influence
around her daughter and prays to God to show
the “spoiled” kids the correct path to life.
On the way home, Carrie asks Margaret why she
never taught her about menstruation but Margaret
doesn’t answer. Before getting out of the car,
a neighbor kid calls Carrie a weirdo. She looks
at him and makes him fall off his bike. Similar
strange things have been happening to her for
the past few months and she doesn’t know why.
Inside the house, Margaret is banging her head
against the wall, apologizing to God for creating
her daughter who will someday sin as she sinned
with her former husband. She even creates fake
bible verses to make Carrie believe that bleeding
on a period is a sin and she has become a sinner.
Carrie knows that her mother is lying because
Ms. Desjardin explained everything about
menstruation earlier. She retaliates that it
is normal and every girl gets it. This makes
Margaret knock her in the head with a bible.
She locks her inside a tiny “praying closet”
asking her to come out only when she has asked
for forgiveness from God. Carrie yells in anger
which makes the door crack. She then lays eyes
on a sculpture of Jesus that starts to bleed.
Somewhere else, Sue and her boyfriend Tommy are
in Tommy’s jeep. At his request, they make love
in the car. After getting dressed, Sue tells him
that she feels guilty for not helping Carrie in
the shower room. Meanwhile, Chris is with her
boyfriend Billy at her house. Unlike Sue, she
shows no regret whatsoever, even though she was
the one who initiated the bullying. To humiliate
Carrie even more, she uploads the video of the
incident on the internet. Back in the house,
Margaret is calmly sewing clothes while singing
songs. It is almost as if she has forgotten
about what happened with her daughter earlier.
She eventually lets Carrie out of the closet
after confirming that she prayed to god.
The next day at school, Ms. Desjardin gathers
Chris, Sue, along with all the other girls who
were involved. As a punishment, they will have to
do suicide sprints for an hour for the rest of the
week. Anyone who disobeys will be denied access
to the upcoming prom. Chris calls the punishment
bullshit and challenges Ms. Desjardin to make her
stop from coming to prom. An enraged Ms. Desjardin
suspends her and revokes her prom privileges.
Chris protests and tries to rally the other
girls to join her but no one supports her,
not even her best friend Sue.
In the meantime, the entire school has
watched the video of Carrie getting bullied.
They make fun of her and even go as far as to
spray graffiti on her locker that says, 'Carrie
White eats shit'. Humiliated and filled with rage,
she goes to the bathroom and concentrates on
the mirror which shatters because of her stare.
Carrie finally begins to realize she has the
power of psychokinesis, which means she can move
objects and people using only her mind.
To learn more about her power, she goes to
the library and reads several books about
psychokinesis. The report on it makes her
believe that like menstruation, having such power
is also normal for some people. In the next class,
she is called to the front of the
classroom to read a poem. When she is done,
Sue’s boyfriend Tommy mutters an insult under
his breath, but when asked to speak louder, he
claims that Carrie’s poem was awesome. Carrie is
shocked and shy that a guy complimented her.
Meanwhile, Chris calls her lawyer father to
the school to try and overturn her revoked
prom privileges. She plays the victim accusing
Ms. Desjardin of verbally abusing her. To prove
her wrong, Ms. Desjardin asks for her phone
that has the video of her bullying Carrie.
However, Chris refuses to hand it,
proving that she is guilty.
At night, Carrie tests her power by levitating
books and her bed. Margaret hears a noise and
comes upstairs with a knife to investigate.
By then, Carrie is pretending to sleep so she
puts the knife down. The next day, Sue asks her
boyfriend Tommy to take Carrie to the prom. She
believes that Carrie deserves one night of fun
and is ready to miss out on senior prom for her.
Tommy wants to go with Sue but on being insisted
repeatedly, he agrees. Then, he walks up to Carrie
and asks her out to prom. A surprised Carrie
thinks he is pranking her and runs away.
Later, Ms. Desjardin finds her crying in
the locker room. When asked what is wrong,
Carrie tells her about Tommy’s proposal. The
teacher supports Carrie but she also knows
that Tommy thinks of her as an outcast. She
finds Sue and Tommy and warns them to rethink
if they are planning to humiliate Carrie.
After school, Tommy drives to Carrie's house,
much to her horror because she doesn’t want her
mother to know she talks to boys. He declares that
he will only leave if she agrees to go to prom
with him. Carrie says yes but under the condition
that he will bring her home by 10:30 pm. She is
excited to finally be like the rest of the kids.
To prepare for prom, she goes shopping but none
of the dresses are under her budget. So instead,
she buys fabric to sew one herself. Chris
sees Carrie shopping and is filled with rage.
She, along with her friends, plan
to play a prank on her at prom.
On returning home, Carrie sees an angry Margaret
waiting for her. She tells her mother that she
is going to prom but Margaret declares she
won’t allow her. Carrie grows frustrated and
levitates things to release her anger. Margaret
prays to god, assuming that the devil has taken
over her daughter. Carrie asks her to stop
talking but Margaret prays even louder.
Eventually, she makes her mother levitate, making
her go quiet. She releases her a while later,
declaring that the conversation is over.
Meanwhile, Chris and Billy are at a farm with
their group of friends. They collect blood by
slitting a pig’s throat. Then, they break into
the gymnasium which is also the prom venue. They
rig the pail with the pig blood, intending to dump
it on Carrie when she is on stage. On the prom
night, Carrie gets ready and applies light makeup.
She looks stunning but is very nervous.
Margaret asks her to dress modestly but Carrie
doesn’t bother arguing with her. Margaret
tells her daughter that everyone is going
to laugh at her which makes Carrie more nervous
than she already is. She locks her mother in the
praying closet before making her way out. Tommy
is speechless when he sees her. They go to the
prom hand in hand and Tommy introduces her to his
friends. Ms. Desjardin also compliments her dress
and asks her to have fun. With time, she loosens
up and feels much more comfortable around Tommy.
A while later, the two slow dance together.
The night cannot get any better for Carrie but
then, Billy and Chris break into the venue. They
wait under the temporary stage to execute their
plan. They have rigged the Prom King and Queen
election to ensure Carrie and Tommy are elected.
When the couple climbs to the
stage to receive the awards,
they will drop the bucket of blood on her.
Before the election, Chris sends Sue a text
that says they are about to humiliate Carrie. A
horrified Sue races to the prom to stop her.
Soon, Tommy and Carrie win the titles of Prom
king and queen. They are called to the stage
as everyone applauds for them. Sue also gets
to the building and sees Chris in the rafters
seconds away from dumping the blood on Carrie.
Ms. Desjardin sees Sue and thinks she is here
to ruin the moment. So, she locks inside a room
without listening to what she has to say. At last,
Chris pulls the rope, dumping the blood on
Carrie. She also hacks the monitor and plays
the video from the day she got her period.
Everyone laughs as Ms. Desjardin comes forward
to help her. But by now, Carrie has lost
rationality. She pushes Ms. Desjardin back
without touching her and everyone gasps. Seconds
later, the pail falls on Tommy’s head, killing him
instantly. Carrie loses control of her power and
pushes the crowd away with a single scream.
Chris and Billy manage to escape and get in their
car. However, when the others try to run outside,
Carrie locks all the doors and windows.
Next, she throws the tables and chairs at the
crowd, killing them one by one. She also holds
some girls to the ground so they are killed after
being trampled. The place lights on fire when
she breaks the stage lights and electrical wires.
She puts Ms. Desjardin safely on the stage and
finishes off the rest of the crowd. She then flies
outside looking for Billy and Chris. They drive
away in their car but are chased behind. Billy
tries to run her over but Carrie stops the
car with her power, causing him to hit his
head and die instantly. Chris tries to run over
her again but Carrie launches the vehicle into
a gas station. She then watches as Chris
dies slowly, stuck to the windshield.
Following that, she goes home and notices
her mother isn’t in the praying closet.
She bathes to clean off all the blood. Margaret
finally appears in front of her and Carrie hugs
her mother, claiming that she was right about
everyone making fun of her. Margaret thinks
that she is being punished for sinning with her
husband and stabs Carrie with a butcher knife.
Carrie tries to save herself but Margaret goes
into a frenzy and chases her into the kitchen.
She pins Carrie down and is about to stab her
again when Carrie uses her power to stop her.
She sends several sharp objects towards Margaret,
crucifying her. Then, she cries holding her dying
mother and regretting what she did. At last, she
uses her power to destroy the house. Just then,
Sue arrives at the house and tries to stop
Carrie. She is about to kill her as well
but halts after realizing Sue is pregnant.
Carrie smiles and claims that it is a girl.
She sends Sue outside to save her from the
falling ceiling. Moments later, Margaret
and Carrie die under the collapsing house.
Some months later, Sue is in a hospital bed
screaming in pain while giving birth. Suddenly,
a bloodied hand emerges from her and she wakes up
realizing it is just a dream. Her mother comforts
her as she hyperventilates, thinking that she
is about to give birth to Carrie.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.